i honestly really mean it when i say
that whenever i hear about these sorts
of things one of my first thoughts is
i don't need to make a video at that and
then it just
worms into my brain and
stays there until i run my mouth
[Music]
so as you could probably guess from the
thumbnail that uh this was brought on
by the most recent episode of star trek
discovery this would be episode four of
season
three an episode entitled forget me not
and i'll get into some of the specifics
about this but i also want you to
realize
i'm not trying to focus exclusively on
this episode or
this show much like
always i'm using this as an example to
try and
deal with the broader stuff and also let
me be upfront
i'm going to be very negative i'll try
not to be nasty
but i can't guarantee that i won't get
there
and the other caveat i have to give you
is that i have not actually seen this
episode now
there are certainly people out there who
immediately go well that invalidates
your opinion
well first off in my defense i haven't
started watching
star trek discovery yet because i don't
have cbs all access
but more to the point much like i do
whenever something comes up in a piece
of media that i either don't have the
ability to watch or for
some personal reason really do not want
to
then i will do my research on it i will
do the legwork
i do believe i've done it here and while
i may not be able to present
full context in terms of the entire
series of what it was that is going on
i can talk about the instance and still
talk about my reaction to it
which again is not just about the
specific instance so the fact that i
haven't seen it
is not the point the fact is this is an
embodiment of something that i
can't deal with
anymore so
in this episode of star trek discovery
we um are introduced to
the series and i don't just mean this
series the entire franchise of star trek
the first canonically
trans character now there have been
allegorically trans characters in the
past uh the trill
being the main example of that but there
has not prior to this character whose
name is gray
there has not been a canonically
trans human character in star trek
so this was a big deal because
whether certain members of the star trek
fandom want to admit it or not
there is a significant queer audience
for this show for this franchise
and to finally get concrete
representation not just allegorical
representation
not just metaphor not just hinting at
but actually having it flat out explicit
representation that's a big deal
and discovery has been breaking
boundaries already
it had a canonically gay character right
from the start
there's a non-binary character on now as
well played by a non-binary actor and
the trans characters played by trans
actor so
there's progress being made i don't want
to shortchange all of that but this
this was a milestone
and the character is immediately dead
and what i mean by that is the episode
is more or less a kind of a flashback
episode to
the trauma of the non-binary character
and they're losing
their love who was gray and that was the
trans character
i've talked about the barrier queers
trope although i believe i called it
barrier gays
more specifically when i did that video
which you can check out there
but it does apply to all
segments of the queer populace
this kind of gets done to to all of us
and i also want you to know that i
didn't just look up
the events and then come up with my
ideas about this i've actually been
talking
with friends other trekkies other trans
women who are trekkies who have been
actively watching the show in specific i
had conversations with
jesse gender and with riley
silverman i will actually put a link in
the description for the article that was
written by riley because she actually
spoke
with blue del barrio who is the
non-binary actor
um in the show and riley was able to
talk to them specifically about
this element um
because i've seen a lot of very mixed
reactions to this i haven't seen
any holy positive not from an actual
member of the trans community um
and like just reminder in case you're
new here for some reason i don't
identify as a trans woman but as a
genderfluid person on a hormone regimen
i have absolutely transitioned out
of being a cis male um so i do i do
still consider myself to be trans and i
do
identify a lot with trans characters
and as i said i've reached a breaking
point
on this and talking it through
with jesse and also going back and forth
with riley
and sort of coming to the best
understanding that i am going to
about what happened it
it doesn't alleviate things because it's
not
100 clear cut now let's be clear about
something gray is dead
but also not really gone so gray's kind
of part of the makeup of adira which is
blue del barrio's character
i i can't get into all the specifics
about it it has to do with the way that
trill symbiotes and their hosts work and
it does appear to not just be like a
memory like uh
like a construct within adira's
mind it does seem to have some agency
and like have
its own input in its own personality so
it is like gray is still alive
kind of but like gray's dead
that that is a dead trans person
immediately upon introduction
so as i said i've talked about the
barrier queers trope in general before
this is the point where i'm going to
just say it flat out
writers stop doing this
please how is this still
happening how
after freaking voltron which was a
couple of years ago now
where a gay character was introduced and
then immediately killed off
and everybody got really ticked off
and more recently the uproar about
lovecraft country which
granted they were probably already
shooting this in the scripture
but like my point is it wasn't a one-off
it's been reinforced repeatedly
recently that introducing and
immediately killing a queer character is
a really
bad move so why do you
keep doing it
and i'm gonna pull a little bit from the
interview
that riley had with blue
because the way that conversation goes
it reads to me as though
blue delbario was not
talked to about what was going to be
happen around
their character and was just handed the
script
now it does sound like they
now are going to have more input on
their character
and there is there appears to be some
recognition
that this was a mistake and also there's
been assurances that gray
is going to remain and isn't just going
to be like a one-off or occasional like
will keep popping up
so there does appear to be some
recognition that
this wasn't good and that it will try to
be amended but
i still come back to the question of why
is this even still happening
and ultimately i am at a point
where the answer i come back to is one
of two things
and they're both cynical answers
callousness and arrogance
the callous version is you have not
bothered to figure out what tropes are
around the kinds of characters and
groups and people you are choosing to
represent and therefore you just stumble
into crap
that anyone who took five seconds to
look up the tropes that surround queer
characters would realize
oh okay so i shouldn't do that that's
option one
i find that unlikely in the case of
something like discovery given the
inclusive characters it's already had
there has been talk that they have had
consultants from glad
at various points and elements it's
unclear how
that relationship was working with this
particular episode but
they seem to have been aware that they
need to watch out for something so that
leaves me with
arrogance what do i mean by arrogance
well
the way that we end up with this
continuing to happen
is writers going okay
so i understand that this is a trope
that
can bother some people but i've got a
story that really justifies it
or i've got a take that's really
something different
i've got a way to do it that is
worth engaging in the trope and
i'm not going to say it's impossible for
you to pull that off
but the arrogance of that and how often
especially frequently the answer seems
to be no
no you couldn't you thought you could
but you couldn't at this point like i
just want to say stop
stop all together because for every
one time somebody engages in a barrier
queers trope
that it works quote unquote or isn't
awful
which arguably this isn't the worst
example
but for everyone that is like okay i
guess there are 10 others
from 10 other writers who also thought
that they could pull it off
and screwed it up and did something
horrible and hurtful and harmful
it's not okay that we keep
going to theaters when we were allowed
to go to theaters or sitting down in
front of our televisions
and seeing people like us that we
connect to
who immediately die
that is damaging on a long enough time
scale
when every single time a queer character
shows up i get a not my stomach thinking
oh my god
are they gonna die and you know what
about half the time they [ __ ] do
just stop
and before somebody starts to twist my
words around
for their bullsh hot takedown
of what it is i'm saying i'm not
saying trans or queer characters should
be immortal
and should never ever die
i am saying that if you are going to
have a character
die within the same episode they are
introduced
don't do it with a queer character
we die too much already
if you want to take a character that you
have put time in
investment in given the audience a
chance to truly
properly bond with and you then later
decide i think there is something that
we can bring about by killing this
character
i will listen i'm not going to give you
a pass i'll see what you do
but i will listen because if you keep us
around
instead of killing us immediately that
means that you are putting thought into
us you are taking the chance of
continuing to represent us
before you just knock us off
put in the time earn it
if you're going to do it and if you're
not going to put in the time
just stop
i can't take this anymore and so help me
god
the next time doctor who pulls this i'm
gonna lose my sh
cause make no mistake i know i brought
this up because of star trek
lots of shows do this doctor who has a
horrible history of this
that last holiday special resolution
there was a
fodder character that is literally all
he was he was fodder he was there just
to get killed to establish that how this
dalek is killing things
and he has like two lines one of which
establishes that he's gay
there was no reason for that he was
gonna die no matter what but let's make
him gay
let's make this the representation of an
entire community
a spectrum of queer people hey here's
what
dead
i can't take it
anymore maybe i'm just
old maybe i've just been
seeing this for too long maybe
maybe the world has just made me even
more of a bitter
bastard than i already was and i'm
allowed to say bastard because i
actually am one
but that kind of brings me back to the
point i made earlier
when we keep seeing this over and over
and over and over again
it hurts every
single time and it is possible
that gray may be utilized in the future
of the show in a way that people will
look back
and think well it was justified or it
wasn't so bad
the first trans character
in a series that has been around since
the
60s and in the same
episode that they are introduced they
are
dead
[ __ ] you
i don't have a sponsor on this video
but if you want to support what i do
i have a patreon any amount helps
it is in fact how i make my living it's
what pays my bills
also if you're not able to do that but
you want to help anyways you can like
you can subscribe you can share this
video
and as always i welcome
your comments even if you disagree with
me
just do it politely and i'll be happy to
read it
drop your comments down below and let's
talk about it
you also don't have to do any of that
ultimately as much as i railed and
talked about the
trans community and the lgbtq and queer
spectrum this is my perspective
and i am angrier than either or at least
so far as i could tell in the
conversations i had then either of the
trans women i spoke with
i may be taking this harder and maybe
that makes me the quintessential angry
queer
that's just where i'm at if you're still
here and still watching
at almost the end of the video the thing
i need you
to remember is that no matter how much i
yell
and i scream and even if what i said
upset you
which was not my intent to upset anybody
but you me
i need you to remember this
you are beautiful you
are valid you
are loved
you are the council i am just running
the meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]